citizens of the reject Nation it is John and
Andrew Gordon reunited once again to finally
at long last check out the Heath Ledger
Motion Picture musical event A Knight's
Tale Andrew are you excited I am so excited
we've been talking about this for a very long
time actually we actually have this is not
hyperbole we have really been talking about
this for years I have been wanting to watch
more Heath Ledger films obviously I want to
react to them in front of you guys but uh I'm
really excited for this one I've been told for
so many years how amazing this film is so I'm
excited most definitely will Lords and Ladies
of the reject Kingdom why don't you go ahead leave
a like on the video that lets us know that we're
doing okay and hey don't forget to subscribe hit
that notification Bell and a big thank you to the
folks over at prepper for cutting down these
highlights it's a big help it's it's a hard
task and we appreciate them very much also if you
want to support the channel and grab a little bit
of swagger Rooney in the process come on over
to the new and improved reject nationshop.com
we got tons of great t-shirt designs and other
things over there and last but not least if you
want to get the full experience of A Knight's
Tale alongside Andrew and I see everything that
doesn't make these reaction highlights grab
your own copy come on over to patreon.com the
real Rejects and sync up with us you can enjoy
the complete film with Andrew and I we also got
a whole bunch of other stuff over there with
reaction highlights of watch along is included
it's a blast without further Ado Now ladies
and Gentlemen let's hop in to a night's tip
in medieval times the Sporter Rose embraced
by a noble and peasant fans alike though only
noble knights could compete the sport was
jousting for one of these nights and over
the hill former Champion it was the end but
for his peasant Squire Will I Am it was merely
the beginning should we open we have to be in
the list in two minutes two minutes or forfeit oh
yeah looking like Tom Hanks a Castaway I
suppose I believe a year after Cast Away stuff
k2so correct they need to do is not fall off
it's awesome we've won oh he's dead yeah about
that we're minutes from Victory I haven't eaten in
three days none of us have what we need to fetch
a priest no he's not done wake up he's mostly dead
sir actor must report it once or forfeit the match
he's on his way fortunately he wears a mask so
it's okay now or a helmet whatever you I'll ride
in his place yes you will I'm asking you William
Thatcher to answer me with your name that's a
good name right there you have to be of noble
birth to compete a detail if the Nobles find
out who you are they'll be the devil to pay
and pray that they don't because I don't have
enough money to pay the devil yes I'm loving the
tone set right here oh yeah this is the needle
drops movie isn't it that's like the one thing
I've heard is that there's gonna be crazy music
away Rock You whenever I hear this
song I think of the Mighty Ducks
how little sport has changed Rufus siwa
nice and Paul Bettany Jarvis that's right
he's gonna be inside the uh helmet you
know tell William what to do that'd be
amazing the score stands at three lances
to none in favor of Sir ekta Lord Philip
of Aragon stand you're ready look at the actor
he needs three points to beat you so a broken
Lance won't win it for him he has to knock
you off the hall I know how to score Robin
I've waited my whole life for this moment your
whole life I selected he shot himself to death
what happened sir Hector dysentery [Music]
be right in the mug yeah but is he still on
the horse yeah [Applause] best two out of three
oops oh a center of the peacock funny
no then 15. damn never haggled with anybody
before five for Roland who's going straight
home to England straight to the pub for me your
pie the pub that's where I would go we could do
this we've done it by that silver in your hand we
can be champions We are the champions my friends
that's 13 for training and outfitting now the
tournament in rwan is in a month from now in
one month we could split a price bigger than this
one in one month we could be laid in a ditch with
selector I don't want glorian riches William I
just want to go home candy cakes with peppermint
cream he's gonna say he's like what about the
pub what about my eel pies name a man bet with
the sword than I in the practice ring you know of
noble wow and I won't spend the rest of my life
as nothing that is nothing and nothing is right
where glorial taken what's that nothing it's food
for the crows if you can take your coins go to
England eat cake but if you can't you come with me
do some coin magic that was quite the speech but
I'm eating cake you see money doesn't matter yeah
I'm with you buddy 13 silver pieces three
men can change their Stars we'll all have
new zodiac signs by morning God love you
William I know I know no one else will
ah I like these guys
okay
there you go you at least make contact
yeah some contacts better than no contact
oh oh dozens of times I guess that means we
should do it again practice makes perfect
I disagree perfect practice makes perfect
practice makes Improvement whoa that's cool
[Laughter]
that was worth it for all of that
gotta give it to him man Heath
Ledger really does have it yeah
there's something magnetic about the guy
is that Paul Bettany I recognize those cheeks
anywhere whoa what are you doing charging
good vocab were you robbed yes and then at
the same time a huge resounding no it's more
a sort of involuntary vow of poverty okay
in pav Jeffrey choice is the name oh [__]
Canterbury Tales up in here the writer for
a penny I'll scribbly anything you want from
summonses decrees edex warrants patents of
nobility a new gentlemen are well I am sir
auric uh Von Lichtenstein from goldiland and
these here are my faithful Squires delves and
uh foul Hurst I'm Richard the lionheart pleased
to meet you no wait a minute I'm Charlemagne no
I'm sitting on the bus ah hold your tongue sir or
lose it now you see that I do believe thank you
must be established for four generations on
either side of the family patents of nobility
must be provided in my services oh and the road
to ruin a plus clothe me shoot me for God's sake
feed me Let Me Ride That horse a bit and you'll
have your patents try us and I will [__] you
until your insides are out and your outsides are
in your ring Trails will become your x-trails bars
pain pain I would love to see that I would love
to see the outtakes of that scene of Alan tutic
2 and then Paul Bettany probably cracked up so
many times oh yeah man I must have been a fun
day on set son of gibbling son of vendish the
fourth Earl of Brunswick the same vendish who
inherited the fife of Bloomberg Purdue Heralds six
Generations is more than enough like sir who are
you you're wearing clothes we don't recognize
you Roger lewd Mortimer thank you very much
it's really good they uh met him on the
way over here yeah I just wish they left
him naked you know it's more than one way to
wheel the Lance I know one person who would
have appreciated that as an audience member
Jennifer Conley I didn't think we had a chance
oh what what is it was your dark history
I passed along the River Thames it was
there I met a pretty lass she said
her name was Mel speak of the devil
how can you look at Heath and
not smile that's incredible
that he fell for her
that's a fun shot really enjoying the the energy
of this movie so yeah oh definitely the tone and
the energy for sure and the music of course
of course well I would hear you speak if it
cost me my ears that is well but I do not want
silence in my life hey would you care if I were
ugly well yes love me if I was down and
out you desecrate the house of God oh
yeah your blasphemy is
amusing and endearingly cute
call me a fox for that is all I
am to you foxy lady I just I only
laugh just to keep from weeping
because he is such a curse yes of
course I can swiftly pray your beauty
Fades that you may better serve God
say that to myself every morning why God did you
curse me with this face God's Will has a purpose
but may not know it [Music] I've seen this guy in
a bunch of stuff that is lovely familiar [Music]
Devil's wenches are going to hell well Rick
Von Liechtenstein yes I'm Simon the Summoner
and I'm overdue with the sword Arena I must
attain you on behalf of your Herald ah damn
it you were never robbed were you I'm
just a nudist I have a gambling problem
yeah people they'll quite literally
take the clothes off your back
how much does he owe you Ten Gold florins
naked all the betony butt shots man yeah all
right release him but God said give him back
his clothes and you'll get it you better start
winning [__] excuse me too late he's been enough
oh my God jeez e [Music] God
that armor looks so heavy yeah
seems like it would be kind of painful on
your joints too if plates moving around
whoa dang that's like what many strikes
of that was at least a couple [Applause]
well done man blown far from his homeland
in search of Glory and Honor we walk
in the garden of his turbulence
The Garden of his turbulence
[Applause]
killing it
the soundtrack is so fire yeah and it's like
you know at least watching it at this point
in time these are all songs that have been
around so long that like even though they're
you know popular music contemporary
music they still feel a little timeless
yeah buddy [Music]
you're gonna actually kill this guy do it
do you want to touch it
oh God it looks so painful yeah
Whiplash alone Jesus excuse me
don't work for free and I chant jealous with
broken armor problem not mine just drop it a sweat
has a price on it welcome to capitalism buddy
well just as well they told me I was after even
asking who yeah oh the other armors I love reverse
psychology did they say I couldn't do it because
I'm a woman no I don't care for it that much they
said you were great with horseshoes but shape with
armor the fact that you're a woman wasn't even
mentioned they were woke in their discrimination
that was smart I will win this
tournament for you [Music]
now I will I will win for you one of the just
in front and high champion at Saint Emilio Rufus
seawell oh a match it's three Lancers one point
is awarded for breaking a lance on a man between
the waist and neck two points for breaking on the
helmet and three points for bearing a rider to the
ground oh damn talking to her to the audience yes
I still need to hear it or perhaps angels have no
names yeah only beautiful faces and you are your
worst nightmare Bon Liechtenstein from gelderland
your armor sir how stylish of you to joust in
an antique and start a new fashion if you win
my grandfather will be able to wear his in public
again retro man's coming back it is with honor I
thank you not quite Benedict Cumberbatch
my ladies and everybody else
here not sitting on a cushion
plebes today you find yourselves equals
that's what I'm talking about how dare he call
us equals class is an illusion a night by nights
I first met him Atop A Mountain near
Jerusalem yeah praying for God when
he saved a fatherless Beauty from the Woodbury
ravishings of her Dreadful Turkish Uncle oh my
oh my just come up with this on the spot oh
yeah Sterling improv right here yes and that's
that's Serenity the protector of
Italian virginity [Laughter] [Music]
no [Music] I love that name so much that was
uh it was quite a monologue monologue yeah I
would kill to be hailed half as wonderfully
as that for anything ever one day I will hail
you with a monologue it's oh decent is that
I'm honored Andrew 13 gold pieces to you yes
Yes master valhurst I'm well aware
a good thonging is on the way
I will fund you this is some
kind of medieval torture
oh
[Applause]
it's like in glad you're just getting the
people on his side yeah are you not to detained
oh God man every time feel the impact split
in a helmet's visor is narrow but splinters
can penetrate it most Knights raise their
chins at the last instant you lose sight
of your opponent but you protect your eyes
yeah I've never not finished before I wish
to keep my honor intact oh I promise Rufus siwa
like he picked up on a weakness that he never
takes his eye off the target he's probably
gonna use that against him in their final
battle Yeah I'm also worried that this guy
is not being above board right now oh okay
a draw and Cobble is hurt okay maintaining the
honor not bad why didn't Ulrich finish him he's
a man of Honor unlike you what an idiot then he
shows his weakness yeah go go back to COBRA Kai
man you're gonna say go back to dark city and dark
city you know everywhere Rufus Sewells are found
oh dark City's cool oh I gotta see it I've seen
the trailer like a million times but not the movie
women weaken their heart it's big you soft bro
you cannot win okay concentrate angry cakes
Adam wire sense word he said he will win
this tournament for you he wins them for
himself and for his own honor so it's
nothing to say wins them for me yeah
how many of these jousting grams do you get
in a day we have Windows tournament for you
and he is the only Knight that has not
promised to do so I would have him win my
heart reverse psychology is working I'm loving
this so far man yeah I gotta say it's fun it's so
Breezy but like the cast is great the characters
are so fun and likable my lady [__] you were
just talking of course my man she also said
to tell you her name is Jocelyn oh lovely
whoa that's cool that was quite a quite a shot
there is he already facing Rufus oh yeah he is
I guess round one fight yeah well I guess this
is his uh not to get meta but his uh versus Bane
the back break that's right there's no way he's
gonna beat him your spirits are your buddy [Music]
like a fist on it yeah yeah
bump it I can't breathe what oh
bump it oh not bad not bad
huh solid if you're gonna get him in the
eyes though I'm not liking where this is
I'm not like in the tone shift right now hey
go try and blind him I believe that's what
happened in what a kid in King Arthur's
Court blinded Daniel Craig art Malik whoa
Daniel Craig is in a kid in King Arthur's he
is he is so is Kate Winslet yeah he went for
the eyes whoa Dewey Cox needs to think
about his entire life before he jousts
whole life flashing before his
eyes right now yeah someday I'll
be a knight a bunch of sun a knight you
might as well try to change the Stars
can a man change the Stars he believes enough
a man can do anything good dad oh goodness
oh oh dude the lady I believe this is yours ugh
yeah thanks you have been weighed you have been
measured and you have been found wanting smells
like a challenge I won't compete in the sword
again it's the best event no it's Tournament
champion or nothing at all All or Nothing
10 Florence that should do yeah melt it
down I could make such armor you wouldn't
even know you wore it how much would that
cost me just take me as far as Paris we
travel alone take a golden go oh come on
dude my lady would know the color of your
Lord's tunic tonight so that she can dress too
much him ah regret to inform your lady that we
won't actually be attendant oh do not answer
questions you don't know the answer too green
all done um trimmed in a kind of Pale green
wooden toggles gonna be an interesting wardrobe
change oh this is a disaster all right your tunic
up quite nicely give us your jacket what that's
not a disaster Roland I don't know how to dance
okay you just need a little
liquid courage my friend you
run out of joust in a month you can
uh figure out how to dance in a day
the second time we've seen someone
with something up their nose
oh and you can do better
can you oh of course again
I was wondering if you would care to show us
how to dance please please por favor and one
and two three um is that the pinky swear dance
yep I could ask God one thing be to stop them
Beauty I'd asked him to stop the world and
melt with you show us a dance of gelderland
you should have a dance off
yeah well you should bow
um
I wonder how much this was Improv
oh she does I think she's gotta know
that he's not of true Royal lineage
[Music]
production values in this are really
nice as well oh yeah like this is a
full-fledged period almost as good as Role
Models certainly let's do this we shall
oh here we go [Music] I was gonna say it's been
a long time since we had a Neil drop people led
me to believe that that was like the main thing
about this movie was it's just all needle drops
this is just like song three I just realized
he was in dark city with Jennifer Conley now
he's in Paul Bettany the married couple so
many layers of uh Degrees of Separation so
many degrees of Kevin Bacon yeah twist Bend
feel the movement well I but eventually I will
be struck and then death do you at least have
the courage to test it oh yeah let's do this
I didn't feel a thing she's his
lucious Fox I'm just going off on
all these dark knight okay
finished type in your name
[Applause]
drips in this movie man I
love the sound design yeah
my deepest honor to present to you I can't unsee
the Benedict Cumberbatch yeah oh is this the guy
who uh they he forfeited because he was yeah yeah
it's the guy from before Oh I'm worried something
bad's gonna happen oh is he forfeiting again
how am I withdrew Adam draw like that can mean
only one thing royalty wait what what happened
is this gonna buy him some kind of Allegiance
Colville is Edward the black prince of
Wales and Future King of England oh [Music]
my man's wants a real challenge what get
at it yeah yes I like this guy [Music]
oh my God it's okay it's gonna
be good for you in the long run
and you also Prince Edward [Music]
cool still you wrote it's not in me to withdraw
no me that's awesome respect around my kingdom
flower is only as good as its petals too don't
you think a flower is good for nothing ouch dude
a flower doesn't keep you warm and a rose never
knocked a man off a horse either you're just a
silly girl oh no better a silly girl with a flower
than a silly boy with a horse and a stick true no
go to her called along hello
hello [Laughter] [Music]
whoa whoa damn Adam has been called back to the
free companies black prince commanded it could be
gone all season first Joslin and now Adam there's
Mischief of a foot I need to write a letter dear
Jocelyn my dearest Joseph was that wrong well
it's up to you really um it's your funeral say
something about her breast yeah you miss a breast
oh my goodness yeah let's get some bosom bars
going I haven't seen you since a month I have seen
the new moon I have seen sunsets and sunrises but
nothing of your beautiful face put me out of a
gig I used to know this girl once who well she
broke my heart but I used to say that the pieces
of My Broken Heart are so small that they could be
passed through the eye of a needle oh I miss her
like the sun misses the flower I miss you like
the sun misses the flower love this team effort oh
hates me that is what gets me through the day and
especially the night the hope that after you're
gone from my sight it will not be the last time
I look upon you oh you better frame this letter
with all the love that I possess William oh yeah
yeah he knew this is coming she's coming to Paris
did you give me a token she did yeah he's got
such an infectious smile come on give it to me
yeah yeah yeah
I could write full time and a forage for me
French wine is too much for English bellies
what about this call me close tonight I swear
I'm gonna start using that word from now on
bong to make that trip a hundred times and most
importantly because the pump himself is French
oh God is on their side well the pope may be
French but Jesus is English you're on yes he is
I love how that group has they've added
land killed our land
this is great sets and locations too
hey man cleanliness is Godliness you know your
favorite cathedrals I come for confession gonna
confess who he is not now but soon speak to me
speak those words I loved they're playing this
just all in the wide but this tournament I'll win
it in your name every night I defeat I defeat for
you your beauty will be reflected in the power of
my arm that's not what you wrote now you're just
like all the others I wish to hear poetry Ulrich
oh not ready you could get in the zone I am and
why must everything for a woman be run on a man's
schedule that's how the world is meant to work
and I want it now your breast day by day oh my
god dude Day by day's turn no no dude day by day
now may I prove my love to you poetry how I love
that we're staying in a white shot this whole time
I want you to act against your normal character
and do badly do badly lose oh no except that I'm
a loser wrong losing is a much Keener test of
your life sure oh my God and losing would show
your obedience to your lover and not to yourself
really great blocking in the scene I will not
it's the last hurdle then you do not love
me [Music] rocking a hard place boy [Music]
I'm curious how many times he lost
his voice doing his monologues yeah
sure you are I wonder if that
was improved or not [Applause]
losing I don't understand oh neither
do I ah yes you do your heart does
Jonathan told me I should lose to prove my
love oh God I'd rather you were blind well
then why in the name of Saint sweetheart
we're doing this for love man the heart
matters of the heart because I love her You
Got It Bad man we're gonna lose so much money
[Music]
he really loves her taking abuse physical
abuse they're just like standing right next
to him as all this happens not even clear in the
field and your love have you proven that yeah
she says that if you love her you will
not lose another match yes I don't have
to take more abuse [Laughter] [Music] now
that I've made it as difficult as possible
yeah yeah do it
oh damn dude that was sick yeah get
a little rail slide in there too that
was a little Tony right here yeah Tony Hawk
action there get some extra points for that
[Applause]
ah dang we've got a souvenir here
we missed you at banquet sir oh Rick hi
Jocelyn me myself and I missed you your prize I
am not worthy of a prize my maid tells me that
sometimes you're Violet and I call you
William here we go Rick yes it is soon
it's just a name at the end of the day she's
not concerned with the actual you know royalty
hierarchy yeah your name makes no mess exactly
yeah just so long as you're of Royal lineage
and I am your
look at all the marks on is that
how you was gonna say I know it
does look you made me take so much physical abuse
[Music]
lovely I gotta imagine uh I wasn't quite
expecting well I was on his way yeah how
long since any you've been back I've only been
gone six months two years three years for my
eyes five belongings 18 years 18 years 12 years
he's just been a pretty state how long for seven
years oh is this where like he grew up it's
gonna be where he gets separated from his uh
director I'm the Thatcher is this the boy
looks like the shirt Alan Tudyk was
wearing earlier you afraid of me boy
it's afraid of [__] show
me your arm got a strong arm
I work out twice a week yeah never skip arm Day
always Skip Leg Day I can show you a great wide
world full of Adventure I can show you the world
no come on say goodbye to your father let's get
started oh no he's a real night William watch
and learn all you can damn dude this site is so
supportive yeah you're a man now oh now go change
your stars and live a better life than I am oh I'm
afraid I've watched I won't know the way back home
don't be foolish William you just follow your feet
huh that's a good line The Boys Are Back in Town
soundtrack is so good in this
movie a lot of classic jams
regular Ted lasso over here oh I knew they
were gonna transition back themselves I had
a feeling yeah that's a good transition
I like that Adamas here is entered yeah
whatever they're fighting no no the black
prince he was forcing to spawn his army yeah
pillaging town after town robbing and murdering
and see Jesus as I promised you before Adamo you
would look up at me from the flat of your
back you will look up and shout save us
and I will whisper no beautiful isn't she a
real Thoroughbred trophy you speak of chosen
like she is a target isn't she yeah trying
to put my Lance in it you know what I mean
I've entered into negotiations with her father
yeah ugh time to make her my bride [Applause]
come on man let's do this thing
looks like the guy was already
falling kind of leaning well he
said that thing about you know like they'll
lean back to protect their eyes yeah yeah
I always sat on you oh I was born in cheapside
just around the corner there well how old are you
nine and one half oh I wonder if you remember a
man they may have died before you were born it was
as tall as a knight that's my dad I remember
him you do well yeah he lives there still
oh sometimes we see him sitting out
the window waiting for a son yeah
he's watching the Stars seeing if
they're gonna move blind sir duh oh
damn someone there if you're here for
the net I haven't finished yet come
back tomorrow we'll tell them do not leave
without saying a word who are you come on
my name is Ulrich I hear that name being Enchanted
from the stadium [Music] word of your son
yes oh very well he wanted you to know he
changed his Stars after all oh God this guy
has he followed his feet oh about his
way home found his way home at last yes
oh
please nobody oversee this oh what a lovely
moment that was great that was beautiful oh
but this leak won't do father not in the chamber
of a thatcher flying Factory is quite fitting
we'll fix it for you
oh I know damn it man God you are so annoying
it's okay even if the truth is revealed it'll
destroy the class system improve once and for
all that anyone from any humble beginning can
rise the ranks if they so choose to commit
I remember Jeff that's the truth this day just
gets better yep yes it does and it's going to keep
doing that adamar I told you last night he says he
saw your father yeah he asked me for your patents
they're waiting for you in the lists they're
going to arrest you ah are you forfeit they've
already marked it down settle the horses make the
rest of your baggage not you what do you think
now that you know what I am not to know what you
are William would take a lifetime sure one I am
most willing to give but right now you've got
to run I like that they didn't turn this into a
melodramatic conflict I love you you and I'm sorry
but I won't see you led away Bound for the stocks
oh but you will see me run no damn your pride
William lose for me one more time and where will
we live in my hovel with the pigs inside in winter
so they won't freeze yes William with the pigs
oh Josephine you speak of what you do not know
dude she's in like an arranged
Contract Marriage Ron William
oh oh all good things must come to an end attend
them together it's been an honor
playing with you serving with you
okay I love this group yeah it's such a great
Ensemble like like I'm glad that this movie is its
own you know piece but at the same time I'm like
I would just watch like a bunch of movies about
these guys yeah for sure I am here to compete you
are here to be arrested get up on your horse bro
ah jeez dude you have been measured big man
it's like come on hit me
with let's start with the head the
victim gets all fuzzy in what world
you have ever beaten me you know the
real one out there when I'm not bound
yeah you're a sniveler you know it I mean like you
know it's a very hateable character but he's doing
a good job I like the notes in his performance
too subtle like ticks in his face let them have me
God love you William so do I
hey someone else will [Applause]
to the pain dude I want to
see her throw down with the
you know with the blacksmith hammers [Applause]
oh I guess they're gonna pull a Bill
and Ted and come break them out yeah
we're pretending not to be one pretending to be
also respects them yeah two sides of the coin
where is Harvey Dent you men love you if I knew
nothing else about you that would be enough true
that's also tilt when you should withdraw and
that is nightly too more of a night than half
these guys man release him release the Kraken
but my personal historians have discovered
that he is descendant from an ancient wow
if I may repay the kindness you once showed me
my liege oh you shall be knighted sir
by the power vested in me by my father
King Edward and by all the witnesses here you
are now an Avenger I dubbed thee Sir William
with his own name beautiful
are you sure yeah it's nothing but SpongeBob
what oh is he cheating you ah dude [Applause]
oh man you're on your own maybe
she went to get his dad maybe yeah
to the pain you just have like a million
of those little fist covers yeah seriously
he's never been divorced come on
oh
nice POV nice POV that's not
good ah oh oh no cut me Mick
son of a [__] I know it's futile to ask but
are there like rules is there a ref somewhere
he is so freaking cheap we are in cheap side
after all yeah good point if he gets hit again
then he has to knock him off his horse yeah he's
gotta knock him down I bet it's gonna come to that
get him in the heart boy oh no oh [__] [Music]
ah as I said in what well could you have ever
beaten me such a place does not exist ah you
just created it man clearly this guy never saw one
of A Knight's Tale and so is your father oh yeah
yes oh I knew it I knew it this movie's gonna make
me cry you must enforce him or kill him the only
way to win kill him that's like 10 points he's
gonna say if she wasn't getting his father I would
have no idea where she was no leave it off uh oh
my she knows what he's doing I can barely grip it
left hand flash it to my own what Funk me
School band is here as long as
they're Kinder than the school
band from Halloween kills I mean excuse me oh
yeah dude that's right rally face like this
who rat and sheep and with heavy-handed words
it's Times Like These we learn to live again I'm
[Applause]
and here before you now [Music]
I don't think any movies maybe clap as much
as this yeah this is like an event film
I mean Heath Ledger's got such eyes of
determination oh yeah man it's just something you
cannot teach he's crapping in that tin can over
there he knows this guy has all the determination
come on boy come on boy
come on
is there some cinematic shots I love it yes
[Music] [Applause]
come on get off that horse yeah oh
you like impaled you have been weighed
I don't want it you have been measured yes
and you absolutely have been found wanting
welcome to the new world yes oh what a lovely shot
too that is great God this movie has
so much life man [Music] [Applause]
oh what a cool like oh yeah it's like a fantasy
cutaway almost yeah yeah that was so cool though
I loved it damn the courage to do that with
no armor that was live or die beautiful man
oh ho didn't need his eyesight for it he just
needed his ears ah man he could feel the energy in
the Crowd Oh wow he's gained his or so I love that
seriously that goes a long way little characters
like that when you gain respect seriously I love
both the details like that no like this movie
across the board yeah I know it's great it's doing
so much like you know for years yeah slacking on
my dad is for years always talked about how much
he adores this film he actually had this on a few
months ago I'm like turn it off John and I are
watching this later it's not a sacred movie yeah
love for prevails yes hey Nani ho
oh the different film stock right
here yeah they definitely changed it oh
the stars have moved it's an effect shot
that was great oh how lovely dude that
was so well done yes oh my goodness
who was uh the prince oh play the prince Colville
James fearfoy okay yeah yeah yeah what has he been
in for he's been I couldn't name him off the top
of my head but he's a definitely a name I've Seen
A Face I know I've seen a bunch of times oh man
you know like this movie I've yeah same I've been
hearing people talk about for so much of my life
and I remember back in oh God what was it like
elementary junior high or whatever like people
fawning over Heath Ledger yeah and uh and you
know I haven't seen all of the sort of main works
that I think people associate with him especially
from his you know heartthrob days things like this
or 10 Things I Hate About You um and and yeah like
he's so freaking Charming he really is but beyond
that like I was really pleasantly surprised and
impressed by this not that I didn't expect to
enjoy it I certainly did but you know like from
the outside you know the main thing I'd heard is
like oh yeah you know it's this fun sort of Night
movie that has you know kind of a fun semi-comedic
tone and a whole bunch of anachronistic needle
drops and funny enough like yeah there are some
needle drops in this movie but it's not like
about that and it's not like throwing you a new
song every five seconds like this managed I think
in a really nice way and in a way that is aged
really well to yeah utilize a few more modern
sensibilities and accoutrements but also like
really commit to bringing this time period This
World this you know series of competitions to life
with such care and craftsmanship like again people
talk about I'm sorry we got the song you won I'm
so sorry I'm sorry to interrupt I'm sorry continue
I just wanted to point out we've got your song I'm
sorry continue um no but like this is uh this is
an interesting movie to me because uh yeah this is
one of those where um uh oh God I think I lost my
train I'm so sorry it's all good I'm so sorry no
I mean it's it's the classic yeah you know uh uh
Queen you know uh sporting event song along with
We Will Rock You Yes um but yeah like this is one
of those movies that pleasantly surprised me and
people talk about how you know you can't make you
could never make certain things today and usually
when people say that I think they're talking about
stuff like ablazing saddles or something like
definitely not actually I disagree I think you
could make Blazing Saddles today I think it just
depends on how you pitch the satire and who is
delivering the Saturn yeah you know I I don't
think it's as impossible as people think and I
think actually it's more possible than people
think because we love edginess we love pushing
those boundaries and we do love satire to me this
is the kind of movie where not that you couldn't
make it today but this is the kind of movie that
I don't think would get made today because I feel
like this is a swing and you have to have you know
a team that is confident in what this is and how
to bring it to life but this is so many things
tied together you know it's a Charming romantic
comedy but it's also uh you know a medieval you
know night tale as is you know indicated by the
title but it's also you know like a buddy movie
in a lot of ways and you know it's got elements
of you know Shakespearean and certainly you know
chauth Syrian you know like classic literature
and things like that and it's all rolled into
one in such a unique way that I'm like this
seems like it would be hard hard to pitch and get
somebody to put the money into oh another scene
headed to the pub
yeah uh
yes ma'am come on boy
I think I just shot myself
okay I'm glad we got that after they were setting
up a sequel there because you know nowadays you
know if you go back this far one was this may
2011 you're like you know you go back to older
movies you're like oh my god there was a post
credit scene to us I love right away too at the
offset of the film the tone they set with the we
will rock you and then the crowd is just so into
it but yeah yeah and I'd love to it's I mean yeah
Heath Ledger is obviously the main character and
he's again his infectious smile and his charm and
God I miss him so much um he's he's so fantastic
in this role he's fantastic in everything he did
uh but and I was so invested in his character but
it was such an ensemble piece as well like that I
love how we started with the three of them which
I was already so invested in them right when we
started with them yeah but I love that the the
uh the it kind of just crew with uh you know with
Paul Bettany and then with Kate and I just love
the way they interact with each other and the way
they work together like they're just they're so
perfect together the five of them yeah I was just
again I just I loved all their interactions and
the way they work off of each other and with each
other and uh that scene too and and this movie was
um a lot deeper than I was expecting especially
the whole uh oh no that's who that actor was oh
my God the dad John Thatcher sure that was uh the
actor did you ever see three men and uh um a baby
no the sequel three the sequel three men and a
little lady that's uh that's the uh I believe it's
Edward uh he's the the antagonist of the film uh
because we're not gonna call him evil even though
he was not a nice man in that film but I was
like I know this actor looks so familiar my God
that's why I was killing me all moving like
who is this actor yeah he's he's great oh God
Rest his soul so sad he passed as well yeah I
mean um there's so many great character actors
across this from the main Ensemble oh you
also got Shannon saw someone Laura Fraser yes
um and you know Mark Addy I know I've seen him
stuff yeah I think he was also Fred Flintstone
and Vivo rock viva I think I think that's who he
was I bet you're right um but uh yeah no again I
I just I love the oh yeah he was the director
of payback okay so I wasn't there you go so I
like that he worked with Mel Gibson then the very
next year Mel Gibson worked with Heath Ledger and
Patriot and the very next year he worked with uh
it's you're six degrees there you go um but yeah
no this this film was really a fun time and I like
that they mix so many different genres you know
you got the medieval stuff you got the comedic
stuff and then you have a kick-ass soundtrack
um and I love all the stunts too and all the
choreography with all the was it the jousting
yeah that was all so well done I mean I really was
on the edge of my see when all that was happening
there was a lot of suspense and that obviously
you know like most of the time he's he's going to
be okay but still because I'm so invested in the
characters I still felt a sense of suspense and
all that and I really love uh the character just
from the backstory that we got and that he wanted
to be he just had this dream of being a knight
and I loved all the obstacles he had to go through
and that's something I can relate to and I feel
like most of us can't just dealing with obstacles
and difficulties and you know stuff like that and
that's something transcending the station it feels
like Society is mandating to you yeah you know
and certainly there's that classic element that
so much uh classic literature and stuff like that
explores of you know defying class and these ideas
that like yeah the common person can marry for
love and you know this game of riches and royalty
comes with the burden of so many things being
taken out of your hands in control yeah and and
I think that too like this this was really lovely
in the sense that it felt like a classic sort of
Hollywood movie in that it's fully committed to
everything it's trying to do it's not taking a
pass on like you know they really threw down on
the stunts on the jousting even the sword fighting
uh in ways where you're like yeah you could have
you know skimped out on this and just focused on
ah it's a romantic comedy but I like that yeah
they they committed to every portion of this so
it does feel a bit like a bit more substantial or
a bit like something more Shakespearean or again
just like classic and literary and two what
I really appreciated is within some of those
classic archetypical plot beats and stuff like
that this made a nice balance between certain
things that you know are gonna work out in
one way or another because you know it ties
together nicely this is a Hollywood movie but at
the same time I thought they made some key choices
um that kept them from falling into too many
sort of like rote holes and things like that
like I like that um Jocelyn and Kate didn't have
to become a love triangle Kate just becomes part
of the crew and I also like that Jocelyn you know
she kind of figures out what the truth is about
William and it's not a big deal because the love
is what's important and I feel like you know in
a different movie we might have had a whole part
of the movie where it's like oh All Is Lost she
knows the truth and she's so hurt and offended
by this yeah um and I like that they chose not
to do things like that in favor of doing other
things making slightly more sophisticated choices
absolutely really being yeah sort of playful and
compassionate while also Rowdy and boisterous and
uh and yeah I love the stuff with Jocelyn I
love the development of their love I love the
stuff with the dad and the payoffs of that like
this felt sort of all-encompassing of a sort of
coming of age for various characters uh on screen
here no I was not expecting to shed some tears in
this film and the stuff with the dad definitely
did I was so invested in the love between Jocelyn
and will as well and yeah like I said this was
definitely a lot deeper than I was expecting
because I I really other than hearing it was a
kick-ass soundtrack it was a lot of fun yeah I
wasn't and there was jousting involved I didn't
really know too much about this film yeah other
than it was a fun good time so I was pleasantly
surprised and like to your point too you made
some you know about the uh that they didn't go the
trophy uh you know generic ways in terms of like
the love trial because when you pointed that out
with Kate I was like in my head I'm like I really
hope they don't go that route I actually thought
too I'm hoping they don't go that and maybe Kate
is gonna fall for one of the other guys in the uh
in their Ensemble Group which is fine that they
didn't even do that maybe she did I don't know one
of the guys yeah yeah she's just one of the guys
which is cool I mean I'm but I'm glad they didn't
do the love trial it wasn't necessary and then
um uh that's another thing I was gonna there was
another thing I had lost my train of thought but
I'm glad that they didn't go that route and again
it's just the film was really well balanced uh so
you know that they it wasn't just focused on The
Love Story there was the jousting stuff there was
the stuff with uh his father and I really also
thought Rufus Seawall did a hell of a job like
I really hate it is scary characters so much
um but he did a hell of a job I haven't seen
too many of his films other than Legend of Zorro
film I do not care for um but he's he's a great
actor I I still need to see dark city but uh I
thought he gave a a really good performance uh
to the point again where I did not like him
in any way shape or form as rooting against
him obviously I don't agree with this character
I understand his motivations and all that but
um it's that great balance of I I hate this guy
and I and it's all because the actor is doing
a terrific job committing to a thankless role
committing to a role that you know it might be I
could easily imagine different ways in which like
ah you know I want to kind of redeem this guy or
I want to find a way in my own way to make kind of
likable but here yeah I thought he fully committed
and you need that you know I it takes I think
a lot to be able to fully commit to being the
anti-charm of the movie yeah you know and two I
I thought this um you know had a really just Keen
AI for small details like you pointed out with um
uh I think it's the Scott handy character like the
um the Squire who's always hailing uh Adam are
you know like even him coming around and just
like those little gross and Transitions and I like
that this too is like you're going from tournament
to tournament in so many ways and like you cut out
to like you know them on the battlefield when uh
adamar is taken out of the games and stuff like
that but for the most part it's it's contained to
this side of the world so it is like kind of like
a sports movie too totally and uh I also thought
that yeah again this was a movie where for as
light and Breezy and fun as it is it also has
a lot of really lovely filmmaking flourishes not
just in the fact that they clearly threw down for
various locations and beautiful sets and you know
the costumes and everything like that but also
like the way they shot a lot of this was really
interesting and it accentuated the action but then
you've also got scenes like when they're talking
in the church I was just about to say that yeah
wide tracking shot that feels like you're in a
play for a minute and it's like stuff like that
is like you know that's an inspired choice and
there are a lot of inspired choices I felt like
across this rather than just like serviceable or
you know workmen-like choices and they stayed on
that shot for a good like minute or two I love
how they stayed in that wide shot for I mean
that is straight up filmmaking right there
and there were some really cinematic shots
to Epic cinematic shots in terms of when they
were doing the jousting too so yeah I know the
cinematography in this film was really inspiring
for me personally but yeah I know all in all good
time and I gotta tell you too before we end this
uh I loved pulpit and these monologues in this
film they were so damn good I'd be hailed that
way ever oh yeah I got I can't I mean there were
a couple times too because he's yelling at the
CR I mean like obviously trying to you know ramp
up uh William and all that so but he's because
he's got to talk to the crowd he's got to be loud
yeah I'm kind of curious if Paul pettini losses
because I know he must I know we've made like 10
000 Dark Knight references during this uh
uh reaction uh and I know for a fact that
Christian Bale lost his voice many times doing
uh you know the Batman voice I'm kind of curious
if Paul Bettany lost his voice at all doing
those La unless that's you know he's going
in the studio and doing uh you know ADR and
all that but uh I'm curious if he did lose
his voice but again in on all the the ensemble
cast was great but Paul petney's monologues were
everything yeah in this movie they're so good I
wouldn't be surprised that last one or one not
last one but one of those ones the one where he's
standing on the rail and he's like bellowing and
almost kind of slurring the words at the very
and he's like he says something to the effect
of like you know I'm I'm good you know like or
something yeah and that felt like well it could
have easily could have been in the script but
that sort of felt like an off the cuff moment
of just like I've completed the monologue and I
was gonna throw this out and uh and it fits the
character so we're gonna keep it I'm also curious
too like that armor that Heath and all the other
actors where I'm curious how heavy that was in
real life too sure it's got to be yeah it's got
to be rendered of some kind of lighter material
but even so yeah like I loved all the different
helmet designs and all the different armors we
got to see like how much training they had to
do in real life I'm sure there were obviously
points where there's stunt guys and all that
stuff too but I'm sure like you know there's
times too where the actors want to get in there
and get their Tom Cruise on and like no I'm doing
this myself yeah I feel like you know if you're a
history nerd who is you know about this era of
uh of History uh I don't know if it's accurate
necessarily but I bet there's a lot for you to
kind of appreciate and to get engrossed by or
pause and sort of pick apart and uh and yeah this
is just a true you know feat of craftsmanship that
was also so lovely and so fun and so enjoyable
and uh and yeah I I I love this man yeah I truly
did years in the making of talking about and we
finally got to do and I'm so happy and it lived
up to the hype it did it with honor my friends
so uh yeah leave us your thoughts on A Knight's
Tale when did you first see this uh what's your
favorite moment from the film let us know and
before we get out of here let's do a quick patron
of the day shout out to Sir Andrew of house Hayes
you are the person at our patreon I would want
to joust the most my friend see you come from
a humble background you know of Locksmiths you
know you know a trade but you also have a heart
of gold and courage of a lion and I feel like you
know if I were to meet you out on the battlefield
I would be maybe sort of taken aback like I don't
know man this guy may be short of stature but he
is 10 times taller in heart and in hotzba and I
would be honored to be foisted from my Steed by
your powerful Lance my friends so uh appreciate
you uh keep your pledge to the kingdom reject and
and you will always be welcome in these lands no
matter what your station's status or otherwise be
well buddy thank you so much for being here you're
one of our oldest patrons and uh and yeah we will
never ask you know for your your lineage papers
because we know you've been here and we got the
evidence to prove it so I'll bet and he's got
nothing on you that was quite a funking I like
that yeah we're just here to thong all night long
but anyway love you buddy thank you all for tuning
in and we'll catch you for another flick keep an
eye out peace people [Music] [Applause] [Music]